[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
reprise de nos émissions en direct sur
tv 78 depuis port marly pour
l'université des mairies le rendez-vous
des collectivités de l'ouest parisien
que nous vous faisons vivre aujourd'hui
donc en direct merci de nous rejoindre
cette table ronde et bonjour à nos trois
nouveaux invités jean michel fourgous
bonjour vous êtes président de saint
quentin en yvelines je vous laisse
prendre le micro maire d'elancourt
également bonjour à françois de mazières
maire de versailles et président de
versailles grand parc et puis à l'anc
rakovic bonjour à vous vous êtes seul e
directeur de transilien pour la sncf on
va parler des transports thématique
transport à présent et un premier tour
de table pour vous demandez un peu
comment vous imaginez les uns et les
autres les transports de demain à quoi
ressemblera le transport de demain pour
vous comment saisis on va tourner le
autour de moi je vais peut-être vous
surprendre mais ma conviction quand on
regarde l'île de france
cette mégapole qui est en croissance
permanente c'est que la solution pour
lutter contre la congestion dans cette
mégapole et donc aussi évidemment dans
les yvelines
c'est le train alors évidemment on peut
me regarde et me dire lui parle un peu
près 100 voitures volantes voilà je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas effectivement
aux taxis volant je crois évidemment à
toutes les mobilités douces aux vélos
libre-service autre tiers est électrique
à la voiture autonome mais j'y crois
comme la solution au premier et au
dernier kilomètre et je n'y crois pas
comme la salle la solution à la
congestion parce que le premier défi
qu'on va devoir relever de demain c'est
évidemment le défi de l'écologie mais
c'est aussi le défi de la congestion
on va en parler plus en détail tout à
l'heure avec vous françois de mazières
vous partager cette vision
oui enfin je crois que c'est une
aujourd'hui il faut une combinaison tous
les moyens il est évident qu'au coeur
des transports il ya les transports
dilou ses terres
dans le train mais on ne peut pas faire
abstraction aussi la nécessité d'avoir
des lignes de bus qui sont d'ailleurs
relié au train d'où des pôles
multimodaux commencer les combien
inaugurés à versailles chantiers et
également c'est vrai que les mobilités
douces se sont beaucoup développés ces
derniers temps et le vélo électrique est
en train de changer les comportements
des vélos c'est évident aussi donc c'est
la combinaison des différents modes qui
permettra de résoudre le problème sur la
région ile de france qui est le problème
numéro 1 notamment pour le développement
économique et pour le quotidien des
franciliens
l'enjeu est réel bien évidemment cet
attrait économique aussi pour faire
venir toutes ces entreprises il faut
encore que lé transports fonctionnent
fonctionne bien ces incompétents aux
intercommunalités la première chose que
les entreprises nous demandent je sais
que jean michel dira la même chose sans
doute c'est d'avoir des transports
efficaces ces transports efficaces du
côté de saint quentin en yvelines
comment vous les imaginez pour demain
justement alors d'abord le monde
la planète est en train de voir la plus
grande transformation de l'organisation
du travail du fait de la révolution du
numérique
donc les postes de travail demain vont
pas ressembler à ceux d'aujourd'hui
donc faut avoir le télétravail par
exemple qui bien sûr intervient sur
après les transports ou pas il y a bien
sûr des tirs lieu pour travailler que
qu'aujourd'hui on obligé d'organiser on
voit bien un changement formidable
extraordinaire imprévisible d'ailleurs
et ce n'est que le début et donc faut
aussi se projeter sur qu'est-ce que ce
sera un poste de travail demain je vois
qu'avec airbus on travaille sur un
projet de bus
protéger parce que airbus trice des
sujets bien sûr très classifiés donc il
faut des conditions pour que les
ingénieurs puissent continuer à
travailler dans le moyen de transport
donc on sent qu'à une multiplicité
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai que dit mon
éminent collègue de versailles
bien entendu c'est un problème crucial
pour les entreprises de compétitivité
mais je crois qu'il faut être conscient
le numérique c'est là c'est le plus
grand des multiplicateurs d'innovation
au monde le plus grand des
multiplicateurs de croissance
donc il faut bien intégrer demain 80%
des postes seront directement liés au
numérique et que ça modifie complètement
les règles gens qu'il faut bien inclure
tout ça il ya aussi la 5g il ya aussi la
voiture autonome nous-mêmes saint
quentin on a été élu dans une des sept
expériences françaises sur l'a5 g62 du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
notamment comment sur le site du
vélodrome de 50 ans dit je le cite
vélodrome la maison c'est une façon
d'expérimenter que si demain on veut la
voiture autonome peut-être plus tôt que
les autres parce qu'on a on a des sites
olympiques
à versailles et à 4 à saint quentin
c'est vrai que si on pouvait avoir la
voiture autonome ou le bus autonome
pour 2024 donc on se bat là dessus avec
d'ailleurs l'aide de valérie pécresse
aussi avec l'aide du département bien
sûr mais on reste optimiste et une
démultiplication des moyens de transport
aujourd'hui qui est quand même
encourageant
d'ailleurs faut mettre de l'ordre non
parce qu'il y en a tellement qui se
démultiplie et il faut qu'on travaille
bien sur mon travail déjà tous ensemble
à dans les yvelines ça se passe très
bien entre les trois collectivités enfin
je pense que celle de paris saclay donc
voila nous on est très optimistes mais
il faut faire confiance à la révolution
scientifique et technique qui va très
très vite aujourd'hui faut s'y préparer
à suivre cette accélération parlera des
différentes innovations qui sont testés
sur les agglomérations avec les
représentants qui sont ici sur ce
plateau mais je reviens à votre vision
vous nous expliquer que finalement pour
vous le transport de demain c'est le
train et donc il faut le moderniser
comment se passe cette modernisation
justement oui je suis conscient quand je
dis que la solution de demain c'est le
train ça peut pas être le train
d'aujourd'hui le train a besoin
d'évoluer et pour ça il ya un certain
nombre de ruptures qu'on peut envisager
et qui vont permettre au train d'avoir
l'efficacité qui est nécessaire si
encore une fois on veut régler cette
question de la congestion qu'aujourd'hui
vives tous nos concitoyens et qui est
une vraie souffrance
la première évolution du train et les
technologiques
il faut que le train ils deviennent
autonomes automatique parce qu'on le
disait on a aujourd'hui des voies de
chemin de fer il ya les six voies qui
arrive à versailles
sauf que ces six voix ils sont saturés
et si on veut mettre plus de trains eh
bien il faut qu'ils soient autonomes
parce que l'autonomie ça permet en fait
plus de fréquences c'est pas le fait de
faire disparaître un conducteur
ça c'est pas le sujet il y aura toujours
un conducteur mais il faut qu'on puisse
avoir plus de trains j'ai eu m
problème avec le micro je vous laisse
comprendre j'essaie dont il faut qu'on
puisse avoir plus de trains sur une même
infrastructure et pour ça il faut des
trains autonome qui accélère et qui
freinent tous de la même manière on va
le faire avec le rer e qui va arriver
dans les yvelines qui va arriver à monte
et ce rer e ce sera le premier train à
pouvoir aller à 120 kilomètres/heure
sous paris avec une fréquence de 100 8
secondes un train toutes les 108
secondes et là on voit bien que on va
voir ce que demandent nos voyageurs
c'est à dire évidemment de la qualité de
service de la régularité mais aussi de
la fréquence ce qui est indispensable si
on veut que les gens fassent ce report
modal qu'on demande temps c'est à dire
que les gens abandonnent non pas la
voiture mais l'autosolisme le fait
d'être seul en voiture pour prendre les
transports en commun on est les la
jonction de tous ses moyens de transport
et on parle de paul ii pôle multimodal
dans ces cas là et sur versailles c'est
quelque chose qui s'est mis en place
également ces derniers mois oui tout est
vrai ce sont des lieux absents
fondamentaux dans la ville contemporaine
où vous avez la conjonction de
l'ensemble des ses moyens de transport
je crois qu aussi une des évolutions
marquantes du momo c'est la réponse à la
question environnementale
ce que les élus demandent c'est des
transports mais c'est aussi des
transports qui soit écologique et
notamment la révolution des bus passera
nécessairement par son dos des bus
électriques ou des bus à hydrogène sur
versailles chantiers ce que nous sommes
en train d'expérimenter c'est
effectivement une présence d'une gare
très importante parce que garder
chantier on estime que ces quatre-vingt
mille passagers jour avec les
changements de caisse compris et nous
avons aujourd'hui est donc quatorze cas
bus qui ont été créés pour qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout de cette transformation il
faudra envisager que ces bus qui vont
traverser la ville de versailles et des
villes avoisinantes avec une très forte
densité avec un nombre de buts très
importants sur certains lits et bien il
faut que ces bus soient écologiquement
correct et donc c'est pour moi la
l'étape supplémentaire sous les qu'il
faut franchir
c'est évidemment comme à l'instant vous
le disiez des lignes qui fonctionne bien
régulièrement il y avait encore pas mal
de progrès à faire on a beaucoup de
plaintes sur certaines lignes par ce que
il ya une saturation parce que les
équipes en sont anciens cette régularité
et en assurer il faut aussi que le
transport pour aller les points plus
éloignés des gars soient des transports
qui correspondent
la nouvelle vision qu'on a de la ville
et c'est ça c'est cette combinaison tout
ça qui va permettre d'avoir les
transports tels que les gens le
souhaitent aujourd'hui et je rajoute
bien sûr les mobilités douces versailles
la ville qui est classé numéro 1 en
ile-de-france pour son action sur les
vélos ça fait partie vraiment notre
stratégie on a la chance aussi d'avoir
une ville relativement plate une ville
assez dense mais l'été pineau que le
vélo est un moyen qui peut se développer
quand on va à l'étranger au masters
dames on va évidemment dans toute la
hollande
vous voyez l'usagé vélo ça correspond là
aussi un nouvelle façon de vivre la
ville et puis les jeunes cadres aime
faire des déplacements en pratiquant du
sport d'une certaine façon
voilà donc c'est ça l'avenir des
transports pour nous un du transport
pour saint quentin en yvelines ce pôle
multimodal est ce que ça vous parle
aussi sur saint quentin en yvelines
aurait coûté le multimodal et on s'y met
tous bien sûr
nous on sait on a un projet aussi mais
bon c'est un projet d'une start up c'est
bien les start up mais c'est plus qu'on
ne sait plus bien sûr plus long et plus
on a haussé le projet subra sky à 10
mètres de hauteur donc au sud et
nationale on a on a le covoiturage en un
mais l'objectif c'est vraiment de bien
comprendre que si vous voulez faire de
la croissance vers vous inviter à vous
j'ai les fesses à faire de la croissance
les choses amis parce que vous êtes
plutôt sur un point de croissance pour
l'instant il faut trois points de
croissance pour financer tous les
retraites tout le système social
français dont va falloir se bouger et la
réduction du temps de travail domicile
travail c'est un enjeu c'est pas
uniquement une déclaration entre
quelques élus comme ça donc ça ça ça
urge mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont dans les yvelines
il y a le vélo électrique il y a il y à
même les vélostation les joies pins où
on en voit d'où sont à 420 km de pistes
cyclables aujourd'hui à saint quentin et
on va continuer parce qu'on a quatre
sites olympiques dont trois sites vélo
donc de toute façon on n'a pas le choix
donc on met le paquet on voit que ça
plaît beaucoup bien attention aux jeunes
dans les entreprises
le vélo a beaucoup de succès on a bien
entendu j'ai pas tout vous citez mais
aujourd'hui alors je vous rappelle que
les français mettent presque 15% des
dépenses de consommation des ménages
dans les transports dans les transports
donc c'est un point important la
trottinette le covoiturage l'autopartage
la voiture autonome
en plus cette voie à 13 à 12 ou demain
on pourra peut-être plus facilement
faire une expérience avec la voiture
autonome
je sais pas si vous avez vu ce que soeur
renault enfin il travaille sur un projet
qu'il connaît assez extraordinaire donc
demain si pour les jo on pouvait avoir
une ligne de cette voie à 13 à 12 qui
nous amène jusqu'à cinquantaine tu le
veux dire que voilà il ya quand même
beaucoup de projets même la ligne 18
mois j'ai été un peu pessimiste je suis
toujours un peu parce que les deniers de
l'état
c'est d'une insécurité dans les
informations qu'on a un bon mais cela
dit il semble que la ligne 18
on a eu des idées des invasions plus
n'est guère plus négative que ça il ya
quelques mois aujourd'hui il ya un petit
peu plus de bleu on va dire que noah
s'est pas encore joué mais c'est vrai
que ils ont pris conscience que le
département des yvelines
c'était pas n'importe quoi que paris
saclay non plus et pas n'importe quoi
c'est quand même la première plateforme
d'hypercroissance en france
vous savez il faut pousser les gens qui
montent dans la politique et pas lâcher
les gens qui tombent mais faut pas
lâcher faut pas empêcher les gens qui
montent parce que c'est eux qui payent
comme tout le système dispositif donc
priorité bien sûr à des zones
d'hypercroissance mais je crois que
c'est pas mal parti elles sont pas juste
des entreprises etc les enjeux
économiques aujourd'hui une entreprise
qui veut s'implanter sur saint quentin
en yvelines me regarde les transports
regarde comment saint quentin est
desservie ce que c'est des questions
qu'on vous pose qui reviennent
régulièrement nommé bien sûr comme mon
collègue l'a dit on a les mêmes
problèmes
aujourd'hui le temps de transport jouent
un rôle important indiscutablement mais
seul il n'y a pas que ça il faut voir
que la qualité de vie les yvelines quand
même offre une certaine qualité de vie
meilleure ça dépend ce que regarder à 50
ans on a un problème nous c'est que ya
70% des gens qui travaillent qui n'y
habitent pas alors souvent il habite
chez toi d'ailleurs et c'est bien c'est
là c'est la complémentarité qu'il ya
d'ailleurs mais mais il faut régler ça
il faut diminuer
il faut qu'ils aient des habitations
qu'ils soient bien adapté aux salariés
les salariés il faut on aime tous les
français toutes les catégories mais il
demeure que les gens qui font le pib
vous avez intérêt les privilégiés un
mois j'ose le dire
l'égalité c'est bien gentil mais il faut
aujourd'hui pousser les boîtes qui bien
sûr sont sont compétitives
internationalement qui sont sur des
compétences de très haute valeur ajoutée
c'est elle qui vont nous sortir de la
mauvaise passe que l'on traverse donc
les transports prioritaire sur des
plateformes d'hypercroissance on revient
à la sncf et à cracovie avec vous au
transilien ont plus particulièrement
aujourd'hui quels sont les
investissements qui sont réalisés parce
qu'on parle de transport de demain mais
tout cela a un coût est ce que la sncf
derrière le transilien
mais les moyens pour ces nouvelles
réalisations pour la modernisation aussi
toutes ses lignes existantes
alors oui on a quand même il faut le
dire la chance d'avoir des
investissements considérables en lait de
france jeudi la chance parce que il faut
dire que ce sont des investissements qui
sont réalisés par la région qui sont
réalisés par les collectivités qui sont
réalisés par l'état et si on faisait le
total on serait à quasiment 50 milliards
d'investissements pour les transports en
ile de france alors
je vais pas parler de ce qu'on connaît
tous par coeur et en particulier des
hommes qui est évidemment ce
prolongement du rer e à l'ouest qui va
être très important pour les yvelines
jusqu'à mantes
mais j'ai plus envie de parler d'un
investissement qu'on connaît moins et
qui est pour moi extrêmement important
c'est la rocade de tram train qu'on est
en train de réaliser le t11 express le
thé 12 express
il était très express si on va jusqu'au
bout de nos envies et des envies des
financeurs sur ces pros sur ses projets
on aura une véritable rocade qui ira
demain des vrilles à versailles hr et
jusqu'à noisy donc on parle beaucoup du
grand paris c'est très bien mais grand
paris ce sera pas avant 2025 on aura
avant ça dès 2022 2023 en fonction des
tronçons une rocade de tram train et
c'est pour la sncf
un projet très important très important
aussi évidemment pour l'île de france
le quotidien des utilisateurs de des
usagers de la sncf du transilien est
plutôt difficile en région parisienne on
peut leur promettre des améliorations
assez rapide c'est vrai que nous on
n'entend évidemment beaucoup les gens
qui se plaignent et on n'entend jamais
les gens qui sont satisfaits c'est
normal moi j'aurais quand même souligner
que si je ne prends que les lignes qui
vont en yvelines
on a en comparer en 2019 et 2018 une
amélioration de la régularité assez
importante en gros de trois points sur
la ligne rennes qui va à saint quentin
de trois points aussi de la ligne bulle
qui va de saint quentin jusqu'à la
défense on a aussi une bonne année sur
la ligne c alors ça ça ne gomme pas les
gros incident qu'on a trop régulièrement
c'est vrai est qui et qui provoque de la
souffrance chez nos voyageurs il faut
avoir en tête que on est en train de
renouveler complètement le réseau qui
est c'est vrai trop anciens on n'a pas
fait suffisamment d'investissements
pendant 30 ans et on essaie de refaire
en dix ans qu'on n'a pas fait en 30 ans
donc ça se fait pas sans casser des
oeufs
forcément ça a des conséquences mais
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle qu'on
ait les moyens
renouveler ce réseau parce
qu'aujourd'hui on sait que c'est
absolument indispensable si on veut
cette qualité de service et puis on est
en ile-de-france on à la région
ile-de-france qui a prévu de mettre 10
milliards d'euros sur des nouveaux
trains on aura en 2025 que des nouveaux
trains en île de france
ça n'était jamais arrivé et ça aussi
c'est un facteur de qualité de service
de confort et ça va changer la vie de
nos concitoyens
on vient juste pour terminer sur les
initiatives qui sont menées du côté de
versailles grand parc et peut-être aussi
on réfléchit tout de même on parlait des
transports existant déjà et de leur
modernisation en cours mais il ya aussi
des tests qui sont réalisés du côté de
versailles satory notamment puis alors
nous avons instauré le pôle vd cob et
d'école c'est donc la réflexion des
grandes entreprises françaises renault
psa valeo sur le véhicule de demain et
qui est le véhicule au automnaux c'est
une chance effectivement pour notre
ville d'avoir ce pôle de recherche avec
plus de 150 aujourd'hui ingénieur qui
travaille dans ce site jeu très
importante par rapport à ce qui vient
d'être dit sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
est en sang de révolution des transports
en ile de france
le projet du grand paris est un projet
absolument majeur l'ouest et moins loin
seule ile-de-france et moins impacté que
l'est nous avons la problématique de
l'es18 puisque c'est la ligne importante
de l'ouest et l'ile-de-france
elle est comme le disait tout alain jean
michel fourgous action déterminante
cette ligne visite pour notamment
réussir le très grand projet qu'est
celui de saclay et c'est là où il faut
voir la cohérence finalement aux d'un
développement d'une région
si on fait ça clé il est évident qu'il
faut avoir un mode de transport qu'ils
soient un mode de transport importants
sont peut-être qu'un métro ou qu'un
système de type train le retard qu'a été
pris qui est maintenant j'espère en
train d'être rattrapé et doigté et
essentielle est essentielle si vous
voulez que cette ligne existe rapidement
aussi on veut dans une corée ensemble
du développement des transports sur
notre partie ouest de l'île de france
nous sommes optimistes ou même des
choses qui se passent devant avec aussi
l'arrivée prochaine donc de cette ligne
nouvelle qui fera le contournement et
qu'il outre en 13 30 13 devrait être
inaugurée en 2021
c'est important effectivement ce lien
sur les entre notamment saint germain et
saint cyr parce que ça me permet de
désenclaver tout de ces villes qui sont
appelées à se développer à permettre de
résoudre le problème de la population en
ile de france
mais pour citer cet exemple on en
discuter ensemble tout à l'heure c'est
que ce sont souvent des étapes et
transport évolué saint cyr c'est une
étape avant que le 30 13 arrive à
versailles qui est le point logique
d'aboutissement de cet hymne est à ce
moment là on arrivera à ce bouclage qui
est essentiel parce qu'il faut jamais
oublier que 70% des transports des
déplacements en ile-de-france ne se font
pas de l'extérieur de paris vers paris
puisque notre système de transport a été
conçu à la fin 19e et au début du 20e
siècle comme un système radial c'est à
dire qu'on venait finalement des villes
xt à versailles un pari est on arrivé à
la capitale avec les 70 % des
déplacements se font en réalité sur le
pourtour de paris et donc le
développement de ces nouveaux systèmes
temps soir est essentielle pour éviter
que les gens sont obligés de passer par
le coeur de paris pour ensuite repartir
vers un autre destination au sein de
l'ile-de-france
voilà donc c'est une révolution et aucun
en train d'être menées et nous espérons
que les le calendrier sera tenu
talon refermer ce plateau consacré aux
transports juste un mot jean michel
fourgous vous l'avez abordé tout à
l'heure sur cette navette supra sky très
brièvement est ce qu'on peut donner un
peu plus de détails sur ce à quoi ça
ressemblera et à quelle échéance
alors bien sûr ça fait rêver tout le
monde s'est tu
des très jolies kamina à 10 mètres de
hauteur au dessus des mêmes des
autoroutes ou la météo milieu vous
prélevez pas de nouveaux foncier ça fait
rêver bon mais c'est une start up qui
fait faillite mais formidable travail
mais il faut qu'il soit prêt pour les jo
alors donc voilà il ya iard il faut une
et d'égout travailler sur les transports
publics mes chers amis en france
l'administration
vous connaissez le problème français la
législation est laid et d'une abondance
ce qui fait que ça ferait une
considérable pour répondre à tous à
toutes les contraintes
une start up est toujours un peu fragile
on faut il faut qu'elle soit renforcée
par des grands gros parce que c'est un
vraiment un moyen de transport très
innovant qui plaît tout le monde s'est
vivement ça fait unanimité mais c'est
une belle idée s'appelait toujours mais
voilà il faut la réaliser c'est long
mais en tout cas on met le maximum
seulement je voulais dire une chose la
voiture tourne son attention parce que
la nationale 10 ont mis on met 120
millions sur l'enfouissement la
nationale 10 bon très bien parce qu'il y
avait des pulsions demain dans cinq ans
ben je fais deux heures me disait
récemment que la voiture autonome quand
même faut envisager que dans les cinq à
dix à quinze ans selon la législation
notre grande administration française et
les assurances également donc aux images
ici à 5 ans vous avez à saint quentin ou
dans les yvelines en général la voiture
autonome dire qu'il ya beaucoup de chose
sur lequel on travaille actuellement
faut faut mettre tous à jose que c'est
pas le sais c'est pas de pollution
sonore c'est pas de pollution tout court
et en même temps les voitures autonomes
vous montez à deux fois plus dedans
c'est pas une voiture compagnie tout
seul puisque vous rentrez pour
travailler pour aller à votre boulot c
c'est une autre conception et donc ça va
complètement ça va baisser le niveau
d'activité sur les routes
donc voilà il faut aussi être capable
d'intégrer à cinq à dix ans que on va
avoir une totale transformation de ce
mode de transport avec la voiture
tonneau et et deux et des conditions de
travail du poste de travail on pourrait
intégrer tout ça c'est notre rôle
on réfléchit en échanges et en toussant
régulièrement merci à tous les trois ans
d'avoir participé à cette table ronde
consacrée au transport je précise pour
ceux qui veulent en savoir un peu plus
sur votre vision des du train de demain
à cracovie qui avait cet ouvrage
metropolit rang et vous avez publié et
dans lequel vous vous expliquer
justement que l'avenir du transport
passe par le train voilà pour résumer
brièvement votre pensée merci encore à
tous les temps et puis ces différents
rendez vous sur l'antenne de tv 78
depuis port marly se poursuivre a tout
de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]